I Gabriel welcome to the Dave Ramsey
show I think you for taking my call
sure what's up I have a $65,000 and
theology student loan that I took to
become a pastor and I'm working at the
pastored and bringing home about 45,000
and I have a girlfriend that she's going
to dental school and she'll be done next
year and she's gonna come out with forty
four hundred and fifty thousand on that
and so I don't know where to start I
just started watching you on YouTube a
few weeks back and I just want to know
where to start so she graduates in two
years yeah mm-hmm in two years yeah
about a year and a half okay when do you
think you all will get married have you
thought about that yet um thinking
probably like next year December next
year okay all right well before you're
married we don't combine anything but
after you're married we combine
everything so between now that I'm
you're married you need to save money
for the wedding and you need to pay it
work extra jobs because a lot of pastors
are by vocational as you know to earn
yeah and that kind of stuff okay so and
you throw that all at your debt you
clean up as much of your debt as you can
possibly clean up that's your goal and
then from there you are as soon as you
all are married the two of you begin to
attack the debt with a vengeance and she
does not need to act like she's rich
she's not she's broke yeah she's 450
freakin thousand dollars in the hole
she's broke right yeah and so we're
gonna you know get her out there making
100 grand you're making 45 we're gonna
work through these student loan debts
it's our sole goal our only goal we're
going to completely focus on it and
gonna be you know that's all we do and
we're not gonna spend any money we're
not gonna be buying a house we're gonna
be buying a bunch of stuff we are a
baroque baroque and we've got to pay
this $450,000 off and there's $65,000
off right I mean you're gonna have a
household income of 150 living in San
Diego give or take right yeah and you
got five hundred and ten thousand
dollars worth of that that you got and
you can do it and but it's going to take
you you know three four five years and
hopefully her income will come up even
above that with a four hundred and fifty
thousand dollar debt unbelievable
Wow ah just takes my breath away hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]